welcome to this video round seven
coverage of the World Championship match
between defending champion vishy anand
and the challenge of magnus carlsen yet
we had some to decisive games game 5 in
game 6 both won by Carlton so he's
leading 42 and this is in really big
trouble now he needs a win and this
white game is certainly one of the tries
that he should go yeah one of the
chances that is Celeste let's see what
he was capable of doing today we had one
e4 and e5 ICF I have those load
tick-tock noise a little bit too
irritated there too silent for me ok we
had one in 425 and again oberlin to be
honest I was slightly surprised that we
got this again because um yeah it just
feels like the Berlin and resulting
positions the end game on those d three
lines and simply seemed to suit cards
very well this kind of slow battle
without many young complications or or
tactics I'm surprised I thought that
Arnold would try something else I was
expecting d4 actually but all my guess
is in this match rubbish anyway so don't
I'm not taught too disappointed that I
was wrong again ok he played d three
actually again not trying the endgame
Bishop c5 just like in the previous game
and now Bishop takes c6 this line has
been played numerous times by the many
top players also by anand Carson is
plated also so it's a it's a popular
line after d takes
enter here are not place night BTW to
hear there are also other moves like h3
for example preventing the bishop
development to g4 but night BTW to is
the recently most popular move also
played by on modern ones um yeah what is
White's idea in this position the idea
is to to play a long game and keep
pieces on the board you have exchanged
on c6 but what you try to do is in the
long run play for f4 very very long run
it takes a long long time to get it
prepared or treat them minor pieces in a
way that at the end you get this typical
endgame edge of the exchange Roy it's a
it's a bit difficult to get to that
though the typical structure rises if
those pawns are exchanged and then white
is got four against three on the on the
King side and it's a maneuvering game
and therefore I'm a bit surprised that
are none went for that I thought he
would try something more more drastic
there were people in the or the
commentators even we expected something
like the King's gambit well I didn't
didn't think about that one and I'm also
pretty sure that Carson has something
prepared against that but I thought
maybe the Scott Shaw or deform some some
other opening okay we got Bishop g4 this
is a rare move only played once or twice
before but quite natural pinning the
night age three and Bishop to h5 and now
again I I was surprised at least a bit
I'm not play tonight f1 that's it's a
normal move that ideas to go nigh g3 and
harass this bishop however he also could
have played the g4 I thought this would
would be a bit more a bit more ambitious
maybe I'm it's not really helping but
yeah it feels when you're are two points
down you you should try something more
enterprising maybe it's not it's not
really great but but anyway gain some
space and try to make this Bishop look
offside black can play 97 f 6 and so on
get it back into play maybe it's just
not that great for white but ok night f
197 very normal black Beck's knight on
f6 is misplaced what you like to do in
ideally to join this arrows wrong he
wants the night on e six or possibly on
c6 and some after playing this one and
the night should somehow connected to
the defrost gram on f6 it's doing
nothing and this also prepares if
possible f6 however after night g3
Magnus simply took on a three the simple
solution and now played g6 yeah this
just takes those in porn squares and
okay at first you think okay maybe
Bishop h6 looks looks like it's a bit
annoying preventing short castles but
black is not intending to do that anyway
you can play Queenie seven and then
casts a long no problem in the game are
not actually played Bishop e3 and yeah
another piece trade okay thousand is not
exchanging right away Queenie seven
that's logical overprotecting c5 and
preparing long castle you need to do
that and now both sides can so long so
we don't have any opposite side castling
or stuff like that simply m symmetrical
positions of the king and now nitey to
was played yet this certainly makes some
sense the night on g3
only looked at squares that did yeah I
will never ever go to and f4 is
basically the only plan that white has
still left in this position ruki 8
centralizing all very sensible king b 1
and b 6 yeah b6 to prepare the king to
be seven and we got just that and h5
yeah to be honest I don't have any great
ideas in this position it's simply
completely equal white has a hard time
to make any sort of progress you could
think about instead of pushing the edge
porn you can always think about deform
but the problem is that simply for is
hanging in this position let's say you
take and then you lose this important
pawn and probably the game and the match
deform it's not working and you can try
to prepare a form but at the end it will
only exchange them yeah pawns they're
simply not much play in this position
and unplayed age five as mentioned and
now after the trade cars and prepared
this rear ooting of the night okay after
the trade g3 we see that after all he is
going to play a form but by now I'm
there's so many pieces exchanged and now
even the rooks come off the edge file is
open I didn't really get any of this to
be honest why would you play play h5 and
exchange on the h1 the only explanation
that I really have is that him after
losing two games and wanted to play very
very solidly to not lose a third one and
really yeah that's the match am I think
already two games is the match being two
games down but three games it's
definitely
them and he was probably hoping for for
a slide slide press in this in his
opening but there simply just
everything's exchanged Luke age eight
there's there's simply nothing to to
explain here to be honest they just
trade stuff and yeah here the only thing
to avoid this to blunder this born as
the Queen now he is hanging this would
give the game away and after Queen f3
you played f5 not this week attacking me
for so we have another trade and the
draw actually was agree TM we have a
repetition basically and a drawn a
relatively quick draw 30 moves 3232
moves but this was all played relatively
quickly we see that both players had one
hour left on the clock and to be honest
them you don't need to be cows into a
2-2 draw this game on the black site I
mean on a good day em well lots of
people could manage that because wide
simply did nothing and have a bit
puzzled to be honest I'm not quite sure
what what the intention was but it's
always on sometimes not always but
sometimes tricky to to understand any
sort of match strategy I cannot really
believe he has given up on the match
completely you simply cannot play in
front of your own people he's playing in
his hometown you cannot simply draw the
rest of the games and say okay okay
minus two is fine whatever I knew I was
going to have a hard time in this match
he will not do that he needs to try
something maybe he's got some some other
ideas for for the next black game I
don't know on
there's some some other some other
reason that we are not aware of but this
is a strange game for a player whose two
points down if you would give some on
this game and and asked okay let tell me
you in this in this position in this
game what is the mats match situation
like then you probably would guess okay
this is probably a game at the end of
the match where is already decided and
they're just going through the motions
basically but yeah it's it's it's
strange I didn't really understand what
what's going on and I don't really
understand why is going for for the
bulletin again from wears white I mean
Kasparov already experienced that it is
very really tough against this opening
in fact someone posted on them on a
board that when he fought in World
Championship matches has caught so
miserably that it's really a really
looking strange especially it gets 25
1.e4 has the last one in 1995 Kasparov
against aren't the famous game 10 in the
in the open room okay so let's wrap up
this this rather boring game and hope
that we get something more interesting
to tomorrow when Carlton has white um
you can certainly not blame cars and he
is very much content with the drawers
black he can try a little bit as white
but you're to pawn these two points up
and there's no reason to to do anything
fancy especially if you if you can see
that your opponent is playing like that
alright thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed it anyway and I'll be back
tomorrow with the next game hopefully
more interesting thanks for watching